from a wedding to an engagement avril
lavigne shared photos of this sweet
moment in paris on instagram uh you can
see mod sun down on one knee pop in the
question with a heart-shaped diamond
ring in front of the eiffel tower and
mon posted on instagram writing in part
you're too beautiful for my words to
describe i grabbed your hand plus took
one last breath and i said will you
marry me and she said yes i love you
after all yeah avril and matt have been
dating for 14 months the canadian rocker
was previously married of course to
derrick whibley and chad kruger uh i
recently sat down with avraham she told
me now despite her new album being
called love sucks she actually loves
love
i've been i've been lucky to experience
some great loves in my life and you know
sometimes
i don't know maybe it's like a season
thing this person is around for this
song whatever the album is called love
sucks but the song that i wrote
also called love sucks literally the
lyric in the in the chorus it's like oh
not another breakup like nah nah not
another breakup but at the same time
like literally two days later like i
started dating somebody i had a new
boyfriend i like to be in a relationship
i do love love